have you been keeping a breast or have
you noticed this trend that's happened
of westerners choosing to convert to
Islam in adult life obviously you spent
a lot of your career criticizing Islam
and now we have
I don't want to accuse of laughing these
people very well may truly believe in
the doctrine but Andrew Taylor is one of
them and downstream from that there's
on-street interviews with young British
youths with these um Islamic Scholars or
or imams or whatever uh converting them
on the street and they're like doing the
doing the thing on the on the street
have you have you I haven't I haven't
seen those voxpop conversions but
um I saw Andrew Tate's conversion
um
well I mean Islam is just mimetically
it's perfect for a specific audience you
know it's um
it's it's a explicitly Macho religion
right it's a no pussy's religion right
it's just a
and this is it just you know it's a
like with Christianity
you have to pretend
yeah well you have to pretend to be
happy to be losing for the longest time
and you're basically just waiting for
Jesus to come back and rectify this
grave and Justice like you're the meek
shall inherit the earth you're just you
know there's no putting this place right
we're not going to win until we really
until we see you know Jesus arrive on
cloud trailing Clouds Of Glory
um so it's all going to be [__] up for
the longest time and there's no
imperative that we really do anything
really like there's no expectation that
we're gonna win
before anything good happens I mean I
guess there's there's one Christian sect
where they do have an expectation of
of uh
of kind of winning you know a thousand a
thousand years of of millennial Glory
until and and then Jesus comes but for
most Christians it's just it's a story
of failure and then they get to say look
we were right you know Jesus you know
yeah
with Islam there's an expectation that
they're going to conquer the world right
and there's an imperative to conquer the
world and for for serious Muslim just
like you don't have to be impatient
necessarily you can take as long as you
want but this is all we all know this is
moving in One Direction and you need to
be a spiritual Warrior and if you if you
take this really far if you become a
jihadist right you're and especially
doctrinaire militant you know True
Believer
well then you're a kind of spiritual
James Bond I mean it's like it's like
you get to be Jocko and care about and
know that you're going to go to paradise
right like so you get all the tools like
it's it's the it's this first person
shooter that literally get all the good
guns like it's not it's not this boring
I'm pretending to just I'll turn the
other cheek you know hit you know thank
thank you sir can I have another
um and you know where the it's it's
it's a high tea religion right and
that's why a schmuck like Andrew Tate
thinks it's he's had a you know a real
insight people can embracing it people
are seeing it as a redress to women of
the West who uh have been conned by
feminism into believing that these
things are good for them they're not
good for them we need you know no one's
happy look at the divorce rates look at
the 60 of us teenage girls aged 12 to 16
have regular or persistent feelings of
hopelessness yeah everyone's only fans
pathologically flapping themselves into
a early Monster Energy whole or whatever
it is that they're doing right
the answer is a return to
something that's got a bit more Lindy
nature to it yeah well I mean that
that's the claim
that I want to deny I mean it's it's
explicitly retrograde I mean it is
regressive it is backward looking it is
not uh it is not using all of the good
ideas we've had in the meantime right
it's like it's a disavow of the presence
and the near present I mean the
modernity in in the case of Islam it's a
it's a disavowl of nearly 1400 years of
of wisdom and insight right it's it's a
it's a claim that in the 7th Century
somebody was so smart and so wise and so
prescient and so had so had his [__]
together that everything we're thinking
about and talking about happened then
right so we should confine ourselves to
the products of that conversation
that's just I mean it's it's imbecilic
on its face right it's not to say again
it's not to say there's nothing useful
to come out of Islam but whatever is
useful we can use without believing that
Muhammad was visited by the Archangel
Gabriel and got and you know got the
last
You Know download from the creator of
the universe
um
it's just not this is not to deny any of
the cultural problems that someone like
Andrew Tate or
I mean there's lots of people we've
we've dragged into the conversation here
but like all of these people who I've
criticized to some degree
Tate or RFK or or I mean you could add
Elon to this all these people are
kind of living out the consequences of
their dissatisfaction with the presence
on the public stage and winning
a lot of
followers as a result they just like
they I you know they like the way these
guys are complaining about the obvious
excesses of the left for the most part
in other news this episode is brought to
you by element element is the way that
I've started my day every single morning
for over three years now it is the best
hydration drink that I've ever found
there's no gluten no fillers no
artificial junk or any other BS it
tastes phenomenal that orange salt
flavor is absolutely outstanding it'll
help to regulate your appetite it'll
curb Cravings it'll improve brain
function and it means that you don't
need to have a coffee first thing in the
morning your adenosine system that
caffeine acts on isn't even active for
the first 90 minutes of the day but salt
acts on your adrenal system an element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
they also have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy where you can buy it
100 risk-free and if you do not like it
for any reason they'll give you your
money back and you don't even need to
return the Box head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with your first box
that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom